jetliners are basically flying homes
it's a sealed pressure canister it's
incredibly strong
it will last practically forever
i'm bruce campbell and you're inside the
cockpit area of my 727 home
i can appreciate that some folks might
feel a bit isolated or that it might
simply strike them as an unusual living
environment but for me it's always felt
completely natural
my entry is via the aft air stairs which
are retractable and are retracted
whenever i leave for an extended time
the aft area of the aircraft now is my
living space
my very primitive shower is located
there
the two natural aft laboratories are
both functional
sleeping quarters there in the form of a
simple futon sofa and uh bench where i
spend lots of time embellishing elements
of the aircraft
jetliners retire at the rate of about
three per day
for the most part i think we shred them
and then we spin around 180 degrees and
make a home after having just shredded
an aerospace class home sized structure
if you are an extraterrestrial looking
down on this behavior you'd wonder
whether this species has all its marbles
in place or not
people have asked me whether it crashed
here and i simply restored the wreck
that's an odd thing to hear it's it's
completely impractical
next time you're in a jetliner close
your eyes for a moment in your mind
remove all the seats and all the other
people
and then open your eyes with that vision
and consider the the expanse of the
living room
it's a good environment it really is
you